[Music]
hello everybody thank you for choosing
my talk over the others
my name is Johanna and I work at a
startup based in Berlin in Toronto we
are a team of 18 engineers and our main
goal as our main focus is video
understanding using solving video
understanding using deep learning
techniques and by video understanding we
mean here understanding and analyzing
the content of video data and today I'm
going to talk you tell you about our
first project that we tackled and this
is a gesture recognition system and so
you might wonder why did we choose
gestures or what was so special about
gestures and for us this project was
also kind of a proof of concept because
as you all know deep learning has been
booming in different fields such as
image classification speech recognition
machine translation and so and so forth
but the video understanding field has
not been yet so explored and at the
other hand if you look at a video data
sample it is basically a very short clip
so for example something like this that
contains also a very distinctive
movement within so solving this kind of
data set would prove us that you can use
deep neural network - the same way as
solving image recognition so for example
video classification at the other hand
gesture is a natural form of expression
it is a form of human communication and
building a gesture recognition system
would be a first step for computers to
be
keen to understand human body language
thus building a bridge between
human-computer interaction and to give
you a little idea of how this this
system would work I'm going to show you
a little clip so this is a clip from the
movie Minority Report and you see Tom
Cruise using his hands to move
workspaces on this on his machine or
slide something down go further in the
video zoom in zoom out so that's
basically the gist of it and I would
like you to notice that he is not doing
this with his bare hands but he is using
actually some gloves making or making it
easy for me to imply that he's using
some additional sensors in order to
recognize the gestures that he's making
and so
all right so obviously gesture
recognition it's not it's not a novel
problem many companies tried or actually
have built just a recognition system but
they didn't really gain a wider
acceptance among Google users and this
is also why it is also because they
often or always required some additional
sensors so for example you might see the
wireless glove that has different
sensors attached to the glove which
gives extra information based on this
information women we make a
classification or Microsoft Kinect has a
depth camera there were some systems
that were segmenting the body and based
on the segmentation they predicted the
gesture and so on the contrary we
decided to try just feeding a neural
network with huge amount of data and
seeing if we can do it without any
additional devices and so this is
important because it means that the end
user in the end would only need a webcam
or a laptop camera to be able to use a
gesture recognition system yeah and
obviously for the deep learning for any
kind of deep learning algorithms we need
huge amounts of data data in magnitudes
of thousands or even hundreds of
thousands and the natural question is
how do we get this kind of data for this
very specific problem that we've chose
so for example you could try data
crawling so scraping the videos from the
internet but this is obviously not ideal
because first of all this is a very
time-consuming problem you might not
find the right amount of data you might
find that the classes that you chose are
not balanced because there are thousands
of videos of thumbs up by only few of
some kind of gesture that you want your
system to be able to recognize you might
find that the video
contain multiple people performing
multiple gesture or the same gestures
Metheny ously or at different time steps
you might find that the people perform
the gesture from different perspectives
you might find a video that is three
minutes long and there's only three
seconds of the gesture which means that
you would have to segment the video
yourself so this is obviously not ideal
at the other hand you could try
collecting and so recording and
annotating the data within your team but
in practice this is obviously not an
option if we're talking about thousands
of videos so our solution for that was
building a data platform that enables us
to generate video data in-house and the
basic principle of the data platform is
putting a task via services like Amazon
Mechanical Turk a task in this content
we call crowd acting which I'm going to
talk in a second and this is obviously
the basic principle of the data platform
but there is way more effort required
into building a platform that would
provide us with some of the largest
video data sets in the world and to
begin with crowd acting is something
very different from data labeling which
is a common practice when collecting
large data sets but we took it kind of a
step further where we say we want this
specifically this specific label and we
put up a task with very specific
instructions and we ask what the workers
to record themselves doing this action
and in order to make this process robust
we've implemented some key features so
one of them would be on the fly
validation which may seem very
straightforward I mean
basically that the feet that the worker
gets an immediate feedback in case there
was something technically wrong with the
video so for example there was some
problem with the video format it was not
a video it was too big or too small and
this is this sounds very obvious but
it's actually crucial when keeping in
mind that at the other side of the
screen there is actual human being that
weights a reward for their labor and
also this human factor is essential when
we think that we rely on the community
of workers to work with us in the long
run and so keeping that in mind we've
implemented a very clear and
user-friendly interface where the user
is guided through the entire process he
gets very specific instructions he is
shown an example video that he has to
imitate himself and he clicks through
all the gestures that we ask we also
keep a very open communication with the
workers we provide them feedback
whenever the video was approved or
rejected we give them a chance to redo
the task in case there was some little
criteria that didn't meet our
requirements and at the end of the
pipeline there is a theme of crowd
acting supporters that verify the videos
and check if all the criteria that we
asked for are met in this way we've
collected the data set that we used to
to train our gesture recognition system
we call it the 20 bien gesture and this
is a dataset containing around 150,000
of videos with 27 different gestures you
can see the example of the gestures over
there it is also free for academic use
so you can just feel free to download it
and try to build your own gesture
recognition system so that's basically
how we got the data very high quality
and then slipped label data
all right so now we specified our
problem and we have the data we can
start training but what happened is
during our initial trainings we've
noticed a problem that we call the
starving GPU problem and basically what
happens is so for example in image
datasets or in image recognition cases
the image data sets is usually small
enough to fit into the file system cache
so during the training the initial
Epoque the first epoch would be a little
bit slower because of the data reading
but in the next in the next iterations
the data reading won't become your
bottleneck whereas in the case of videos
because you have for example 150
thousands of videos they do not fit into
the file system cache and in each and
every situation you have to reread or
read the data over and over again and
that becomes the bottleneck of your
training the more so with multi GPO
training and with data parallelism which
is standard for I think almost all the
frameworks and so our solution was that
was writing our own data format that we
called the gulp i/o and it's basically a
data format that concatenates all the
frames of the video as into a single
data file and saves the offset and the
metadata into the secondary metafile so
the JPEG compression makes it more
efficient and easy to use API mechanic
makes it is it reason about the speeded
that we get is from 9 to 16 times on HDD
and around twice on sdd it is an open
source project so if you have some
similar problems you can just use it it
does not extrapolate to for example
speech or audio it's it's only good for
video and for image state
it's alright so now we are ready to
train we made sure that the training
works smoothly we got the data we
specify the problem and I will talk
about our models and I will be talking
about 3d conversion neural networks if
you know about two-dimensional
conversion in your networks then it's
basically an illogical but with the
normal CNN's you operate on images which
are three-dimensional tensors and
batches of images in the video cases you
have an extra dimension because you kind
of have stack of images as your single
data sample and so the convolution
filter is now three dimensional because
you also convolve around the temporal
damage so maybe quickly initially we
were using tensor flow and our first
prototype is intensive flow but then we
all switch to PI touch which I recommend
because it basically cut down on
development time thus making the
experiment faster and so our initial
model was a so the starting from point
for our initial architecture was
inspired by the paper from Nvidia
gesture recognition system from 2016 and
there are some slight differences so the
data set was only about 1500 videos and
they also used depth to information from
Kinect camera whereas we used purely RGB
images and so the first network
basically took a video split it into n
chunks and fed each chunk separately
into a 3d conversion your network and
the output for this chunk at the output
for each of the tank we're averaged and
the average of the chunk prediction was
a prediction for the entire video
and while this worked pretty well we
noticed that in order to to model longer
temporal relations we needed to add a
Aran n layer on top so now we would have
the features from the CN n we fell into
Aaron N and again the predictions of
each column would be averaged and this
also made assist our system real time
capable because in this case you can
just make a prediction in the test time
you can just make a prediction for a
single clip and then save the hidden
state and fed it over and over again so
that you're kind of imitating the
training scenario in the test scenario
and with advances of of deep learning at
some point we exchanged 3d CNN columns
for the squeeze net layers it's it's
basically a computational trick to to
get better features with less
computational time if you're more
interested about reading squeeze net I
would recommend to go into the
literature this gave us some some some
advances in accuracy and speed but
actually the final model for the final
model we kind of revisited the idea of
splitting the video into chunks so
previously the intuitive behind
splitting the video into chunks was that
we compute the part of the video and
then we kind of have some features that
correspond to each time step of the
video we fit it in to Aaron and so that
we have like a time sequence and then we
get the predictions but for our final
model we decided to feed an entire video
into a 3d conversion on your network
with the conversional filters being one
having stride one on the temporal
dimension and three and three
respectively for the spatial dimensions
and what that brings us is this gives us
very good temporal features as well as
the spatial features and so in this case
this kind of an feature so for the end
frame video you would have an feature
vector which then you would put into the
RNN layer and again average the
predictions for each future frame or for
the for each feature that that you get
so this is again how it may be a little
bit more clear how it looks like you
have a video if you didn't do the 3d CNN
network then lsdm in the softmax and you
see that the average would be probably
more most sensible and so in order to
demo the results I'm going to show you a
little clip this is a video of the demo
that is reduced to only 8 gestures I
will be after presentations around if
you wish to see a live version of the
demo with 27 gestures approach me and
I'll show it to you so in order to demo
our system we built a client service
system using Python and JavaScript it
basically consists of several parallel
processes one is responsible for the
inference one is responsible for the
video capture and one is responsible for
HTTP server Inc and as I said initially
we were using tensorflow in tender flow
we save a network as the protocol buffer
and then we just load it into the memory
and kind of session ran the notes that
you're interested in right now we're
using Python and in Pytor just a little
bit more complicated because you
indeed the checkpoints so the weights of
your network as well as the network
definition but this might have changed
with the new and an X package released
by the IBM I think last week and so this
is the demo you see a person performing
different gestures just using a laptop
camera and it works as I said on 16
frames per second and I think maybe
that's enough
and so what you might also find
interesting is that the demo works runs
on animated device from Nvidia it's an
Nvidia Developer Kit TK one and it has a
Kepler GPU with four gigabytes of memory
built in memory so it's also embedded
and since the demo we've been
continuously working on collecting more
data and building models that can
understand more things and we actually
also published another data set which we
called there's something something and
it's a data set of basic interactions
with everyday objects so our goal here
is to build a system that can understand
physical relations between objects and
it's called something something because
you would find labels such as moving
something towards something and the
workers would feel into something
something so they would use everyday
objects that their choose to this data
set has around 110,000 videos and it
contains I think 170 labels and together
with this data set we've built a model
that we call the super model this is a
model that can predict 300 different
classes also in real time and this is
the amount of it
so as you can see this is the prediction
that the network is most confident about
and this is it
um
do you have any questions so we are
actually working on that right now the
problem is that so there's for example
170 labels that are more or less
uniformly distributed over the data set
it is not the case for the labels
because for example if you if you say
pouring something into something most of
the workers or maybe that's a bad
example but you can imagine that the
workers try any object that they just
have lying around closest to them while
they're recording so it's actually
pretty difficult we are thinking about
combining the system with some kind of
object recognition in order to make the
it's easier for the network to also
learn that the objects but it's actually
a very good question it's actually a
very hard problem in this specific data
set I can't discuss this information I
don't even really know here was the
question in training such a difficult
network there's gonna be a bunch of
tricks that are used so um where any
auxilary auxilary are losses that you
use in you know let's say inside of a
deep CNN or different back prop on maybe
are n layers and you know and then the
CN n layers
what are optimized ur tricks that are
used stuff like that because it seems
you know really amazing Congrats
I just liked like to know if there is
anything that he can tell us about it
it's a very good question and so the
process of training was super difficult
at the beginning so it didn't work for
months and we didn't use any
optimization techniques
neither axillary tasks but we spent a
lot of time on figuring the right
architecture so for example we've
learned that you need to normalize the
outputs also before the
and layer as well as within the network
but from that point on everything just
started to work and it is amazing how a
simple network like that the one that I
showed you the end the last one which
basically as a traditional network you
brute force feed a video into this
network upload by hernán and it works
and the reason I think for this is the
data so there hasn't been that much of
optimization tricks as the huge amount
of data that we just have and throw at
it
so so pretty much just putting bathroom
wherever I can and putting data there is
like new data sort of like you know you
don't really go i box but it just
dropped more and more data on him and
right it's something like that yeah so
not really a lot of you know well I mean
it depends how you look at it obviously
we spend months on on finding the right
instructor or seeing what should go
where or how do I choose the the frame
rate for that how do i sample my data
how do i what input pipelines we are use
for that but the general answer for you
from me to you would be not really
auxilary tasks as much as the right
architecture combined with data all
right thanks a lot
thank you
yes
did you try some other compression
techniques like I don't know something
based on wavelets no we used jpg
compressions I'm not sure if we tried
wavelets I'm pretty sure we just went
with JPEG compression because I think it
was proven to be the most efficient yes
I got that but we didn't use wavelets
any other questions did you try to use
different architectures for recurrent
neural networks than Alice TM yes we
also tried the simpler nn but the Alice
team worked better
okay let's finish thank you very much
for it
[Applause]
you